[Music]
[Applause]
the return to Reggie Miller the Hall of
Famer turned his sports NBA analyst and
he was working in the garden when the
heat came in and stole the Eastern
Conference Finals what was it like
pre-game what were you what was your
thought pregame with that atmosphere in
the garden
it was absolutely
electrifying uh in the garden they had
perhaps maybe the best hype tape I had
ever seen before the crowd was Jack they
had a mixture or video of the Red Sox I
believe that was that 04
04 when they came back from 3-0 versus
the Yankees so they had that spliced in
with a lot of game footage and post-game
interviews of game six and I'm here to
tell you that crowd was absolutely
pumped the atmosphere was there
and then 20 seconds into the game
the balloon somewhat popped because and
I said this on air
um and you know this very well your
stars set the tone they set the tone in
the first quarter of how we're going to
play are we going to be aggressive I'm
going to go after that and sometimes
that can have a negative effect as well
when Tatum went down with the ankle
injury and he didn't pop up quickly
enough and you could see on his face
that he had rolled it pretty well to me
that set the tone of how the Celtics
were going to play
again it's just a feeling I have a gut
feeling haven't been in that situation
when we were in the Conference Finals
versus Chicago and I had a twisted ankle
playing against Jordan in the Bulls and
you're not a hundred percent
your guys feed all of that I felt his
teammates fed off of that and they
played like that before we get to the
matchup you mentioned the matchup
against Jordan in the Bulls what did you
make of Scottie Pippen's comments that
Mike when he first got into the league
was a horrible basketball player
I I think it's more war choice that
we're focusing in on here
um the word Horrible no it wasn't
horrible because he was a top three
player at the time he was an all-ending
player he was electrifying horrible
means he couldn't he's like a role
player I I think
um
into Scotty's point and what he's trying
to say is Mike didn't start winning and
playing Team Basketball until I got on
the team
I think again people want to play look
we know there's an ongoing
do you do we want to call it a few
between Fields well there is on Scotty's
side it feels like yeah look Michael
says look I didn't win until Scotty got
here Michael
plenty of tires I think for whatever
reason that whole last dance documentary
really has been a trigger for for Pippin
and I think it was just poor word choice
and saying horrible because he wasn't
horrible
um but he is correct and he wasn't
playing a brand of Team Basketball that
was winning basketball until Pippin got
there that that is true but horrible
not so much but you know what when we
talk about great teams of all time it's
usually Shaq and Kobe's Lakers or it
might be the big three with you know
bird and McHale and Parish uh Drexler
Elijah won when they were together
um magic and Kareem we don't say Jordan
and Pippin yeah we do no we say Jordan's
Bulls no no we say though we say the six
feet the two three piece and you do say
Jordan and Pippen you just don't say
Jordan because again I think the public
does Reg
but I I Mike was too big it's it's
Jordan's Bulls okay basketball purists
say Jordan Pippin the Casual fan will
say Jordan yes fair enough yeah and I
wonder about that with Scotty that you
know it feels like he is still crying
out for you know somebody to hug him and
just say you were great
right
that's exactly it uh don't forget me
guys I'm over here I was a part of it I
mean Steve Kerr Horace Grant they all
can almost say the same thing you don't
hear Dennis Rodman say anything like
this again
I think
Mike and Scotty need to get into a room
and hash out whatever this difference is
between them because
Chicago and that run of six
championships I don't know if that'll
ever be done again
and those two guys are
Central figures of why they're why the
Bulls are viewed as one of the greatest
franchises of all time yeah but you're
not going to get them in the same room
you got Scotty's ex with Michael's son I
mean now you're muddy no I'm just
telling you they muddied up the water
they muddied I didn't I just noticed the
color of the water
look I I I'm not going to get into
people's personal business okay all
right we're talking exes
no no it's it's Scotty's ex and
Reggie Miller
x's and x's and O NOS I think that's
what it is we're talking to Reggie
Miller the Hall of Famer I mentioned
with no disrespect to Joker but he's not
exciting to watch He's unbelievably
great you know great player
but you know the Casual basketball fan
will they tune into the NBA finals
I
the games three or four if it's you know
2-2 and interest starts to build but
uh again Denver Miami it's not
sexy
um but again the basketball appears like
you and myself uh
I want to see Joker play I love what he
does on the floor and for his teammates
same with Jimmy Butler the warrior
mentality the underdog the AC I mean
think about it they beat him one they
beat a two and they beat a 5c that's
unbelievable so yeah their story lines
there but it's not LeBron it's not KD
it's not the Boston Celtics so yeah your
casual fan probably won't tune in until
it matters or means something but I
think your basketball peers who love the
game of basketball obviously what's your
name all right what do you do with Jalen
Brown if you're the Celtics
uh you gotta retire
look you've got two young players 26 and
that are just coming into their own and
um you can't lose him for nothing I'm
sure you can get a sign and trade but
you've got to find a way
you gotta open up the piggy bank and to
me Tatum and brown were arguably
one of the greatest Duos in our games
today you've got Katie and Booker
um you can put LeBron and 80 in there if
you want
um Luca and Kyrie if they happen to stay
together but certainly Tatum and brown
to me
is one of the better Duos in our game
young Duos too let them grow together
and here's the thing they've been in the
finals before they were they just got
beat in game seven of the conference
this is a team that's tested right
they're that close
to break it up now to have a knee-jerk
reaction to this season
um no I open up the piggy bank and sign
that man do you want to tie up a half a
billion dollars in two players who play
a similar Style
I would and I would build around that
again
if we are it's one game if they win game
seven are we really talking about should
we
you know resign him no they've been back
to back trips to the finals
um
two young players I
I do it I really do it's a lot of money
and
not only are they two two-way players
too they both play defense as well it's
hard to come by you need length in this
game and they're six seven six eight
long they both can score they both can
defend Theodore yeah I do it okay
explain this logic to me
then you shoot the three
now you're down by double digits you
keep shooting the three to try to come
back and you're not making they reg they
were seven for 40 from three point range
before they made their last two
can't we get to the free throw line
can't we take it to the hoop what's
wrong with the two can I can I get
something that gives us a little bit of
confidence instead of jacking up threes
that was their problem
all postseason in my opinion for Boston
um but that's how they played all year
um I think what was lost is they were
our top 10 defensive team in the top 10
offensive team compost season they left
their defense in the regular season and
became just it was all about shooting
threes and we're gonna outscore you and
they lost their defensive identity to me
that was in a nutshell the downfall for
the Celtics they lost their their
defensive what got them here what made
them
um so great last year to me they were a
much better team defensively because
this season they let their offense
dictate how they played if they weren't
shooting the three well as we saw in a
lot of games in the Conference Finals it
affected their defense and they could
recover from that and how they played in
game six if they ever played the whole
postseason like that they didn't want a
championship that's how the Celtics were
supposed to play because
as bad as they shot from three in game
six in Miami and found a way to win that
ball game
on the defensive end
if they would have played like anywhere
near that in game seven they would have
beat Miami
more likely to have a sweeper seven game
series in the finals
but it won't be a seven game series
either
I can make a case for both teams
um because no one wanted to talk about
how good Denver and jokic was they're
the most balanced well-rounded
well coached and Coach Malone
the deeper team but we also said that
about Milwaukee we also said that about
Boston and what did Miami do they ran
right through them well that rare
because they did go seven games with
Boston but they were up 3-0
and then got chased down and had to win
on the road in game seven and something
special is brewing
the only reservation I have with Miami
is will they have enough bodies again I
know hero is targeting game three or
four possibly so you're gonna get a
20-point score back but how effective
will he be having been off six weeks or
so
um do they have enough bodies but the
emerge of the emergence of Caleb Martin
throws kind of A Wrinkle in this a
little bit how he has played especially
in the Conference Finals that's why I
think something special could be
happening
in South Florida I really do it's not
like Denver has been this is the first
trip to the NBA finals for Denver
they're a little green are you calling
it are you hinting or are you calling
[Music]
if Jimmy Butler
can play like he played in game two and
seven
consistently he doesn't always have to
have huge games but dictate and control
the pace in the offense and how they
perform defensively yes Theodore I'm
gonna say Miami and Miami and six okay
all right
by the way I saw where Jeff Bezos is
renting a house in Malibu Kenny G's is
Kenny G does he live close to you
[Laughter]
oh what'd you say about Jeff yeah
they're just yeah does Kenny G live yeah
we're all in the same block here so you
live by Kenny G
Malibu is so small we all live
okay are you the most famous person on
your street
yes
but within your distance
I'm a
nobody to a few people but on this
particular walk
give me give me one in the area you
don't have to give any address but just
in the area who's more famous than you
more famous yeah
someone just bought a 120 20 million
dollar home right down the street
and all the single ladies all the
singles and oh
hey
wait I thought they bought a 200 million
dollar home oh was it 200 million then I
short changed on myself yes
I apologize
I got to give you your dude Jay-Z
they're right down the street yes Seton
I have here just a couple years ago a
Canadian billionaire bought a 120
million dollar Malibu mansion and that
had set all kinds of Records but I think
that Jay-Z and Beyonce just broke that
yeah yeah so their neighbors they're
excited they're almost side by side
those two properties
but you don't go like trick-or-treating
over there
right now no no no no Jay-Z is not
letting you on no I need some sugar home
what what Paul yeah the house uh Jay-Z
and Beyonce bought in Malibu 30 000
square feet reg uh price of 200 million
that's a record from Malibu 177 was the
record
well all I gotta say is thank you
because property values yeah my property
values
thank you and then Jeff Bezos is renting
Kenny G's property six hundred thousand
dollars a month
yes
it's good to be back in Malibu
you know what you should you should you
should have rented it out you could have
rented out the crib and then you know
when the kids get older maybe the kids
get older maybe yeah
um is Mark Jackson going does he have to
apologize on the air to start out game
one for not voting for Joker in his top
five for MVP I think he's already done
that because he had them in the Western
Conference Finals versus the Lakers so
I'm sure he heard it
from the Denver Nuggets faithful
I look I talked to Mark he says
look it was a mishap because he was
thinking about all NBA teams because he
was going to put Joel embiid on the
first two because he was going to be his
MVP so he was filling out what he
assumed to be the all-nba team
and that's why Joker was so low on his
MVP voting time do you think it bothers
Joker no not at all
not at all to be a three Pete as MVP
would not matter to him
I'm sure it would have mattered to him
but I mean I pushed him in there
you're basing this conversation off what
you saw in the postseason from MB
because indeed during the regular season
don't you think he deserves the MVP or
was in the running or no oh no he's
doing the running but he didn't deserve
it it's I I think that he was you're
basing this right now knowing that
Denver's in the finals and Joel embiid
is in the Bahamas right now you're
basing that a little bit off that well
no I said it at the end of the year that
it changed when Kendrick Perkins talked
about the makeup of the voters and it
changed because you know the betting
favorite was Joker Joker was going to
win the MVP and then it changed with a
couple of weeks left and and bead played
great that you know the last couple of
weeks he played great but Joker didn't
do anything to lose he did not yes he
yeah Denver didn't play breakdown yes
absolutely I think it cost him the MVP
but I said you know how this works
sometimes it's your turn the media
decides it's your turn it's Carl
Malone's turn it's Charles Barkley's
turn right
right but if you ask the Joker the MVP
that he really wants is still in front
of him that's the most important MVP and
if they play and if he plays like he did
versus the Lakers then he will have that
third MVP it just will become finals MVP
and that's the only MVP any of these
players ever want by the way I'm not up
on Jay-Z lyrics but I know LeBron sent
out a cryptic Jay-Z lyric about
something about being number one but
what about when I'm not here anymore or
something like that
I didn't see it okay
what is going on with LeBron
he's not going anywhere come on he's oh
two years one at 47 and one what 49.50
uh that was emotion talking right there
that was yeah but that's the one this
just happened that he put out some
cryptic he does not anywhere he just
wants some leverage to have Raw palinka
tweak that roster a little bit maybe I
know Kyrie's being floated out there I'm
not sure that's the answer but he wants
control
still wants that control why would he
lose control just because he got swept
all of a sudden they're going to go no
LeBron you don't get to have any control
here
he's still in charge
yeah well
he's not going anywhere people
he's not walking away from have you been
to LeBron's house I have not
Taco Tuesday nor nor have I ever been
asked oh okay the biggest house you've
been to
why are we
getting that's all you cannot take any
of this to the Grave I know
who cares how big someone's house is
give me the most impressive house you've
been in
come on
uh I was probably say back in the day my
Indiana days our owner uh herb Simon had
a
impressive spread out there in Carmel
Indiana
all right but that doesn't count
here you go I told you you can't be a
bowler you can't be a baller in Indiana
come on why not come on
you get a knife
now it's a 30 000 square feet like home
and they know
but it's nice he's Reggie Aloysius
Miller Jr III and he's picking the Miami
Heat in six I am something a special
brewing and you got and you're a bruin
and you got a red shirt on there
oh okay once again it's x's and oh no's
just like oh
no no no not my bad I know I should have
stopped oh great to talk come on now
thank you come on it's not a horrible
that's that's Reggie Miller Hall of
Famer thank you reg Mitch
I want to know about these homes